so as america moves out of the coveted
pandemic the country is gripped by a new
epidemic a perilous surge in crime in
cities across the country have seen an
alarming rise in homicides and shootings
including places
like portland where murders are up over
500 percent
and now to throw more gas on the fire
while
crime rates are climbing there's a mass
exodus of police forces
nationwide law enforcement retirements
are up 45
and resignations near 20 percent
anti-cop sentiments
grips the country and it's gotten so bad
that for example
asheville north carolina city with 90
000 residents has lost over one third of
their police force
so how can we end this troubling trend
here now to react to seattle radio host
jason rantz i'll ask you jason how we
find an end to this but also
if we do not where does this take us
compromise
smaller look worse police forces who
will choose to be a cop at the end of
this entire movement
i couldn't tell you who would want to be
a cop right now in some of these big
cities because no one decided to become
a cop so they can be villainized
in this story that activists are telling
they're supposed to be the heroes and we
know that by their actions
they're not the villains and yet despite
the data
we get this talking point coming from
progressives coming from the left
and a lot of media outlets are just
running with it and so
people are wondering do i want to put on
this uniform risk my life
risk not showing up back to my family at
the end of a shift
just so i can get attacked both
figuratively and sometimes
literally by folks on the left it
doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense and we know
how this is going to end if it continues
going down this path
which is more crime and less protected
cities
yeah so you're talking about let's be
honest here mediocre pay
you're talking about possibly losing
qualified immunity meaning you can get
personally sued you're talking about
putting your life on the line
every day you're talking about
administration politicians making your
job
harder to actually succeed at
and you're talking about being vilified
in your local community when you come
home you're going to either have people
who have just such an amazing innate
sense of duty
or really bottom of the barrel
individuals who will be applying to be
cops she'll have
those two dichotomies let me show you
this though jason this is um
portland pd so they tweeted this
apparently there were some protests over
a shooting
right the last couple of nights in
portland and those protests turned into
riots and damage and vandalism
because they suspected the shooting
involved a black individual so portland
put out this tweet
there's erroneous information being
circulated on social media regarding the
officer-involved shooting
in the lloyd district we can confirm the
subject involved as an adult white male
no one else was injured so am i reading
this right jason everybody calm down
we shot a white guy yeah because the
antifa thugs and the other lunatics who
go out there they don't really care
unless they can see a black person or a
latino person to exploit
for their own personal gain now what is
particularly notable in what happened
last night this is the first time police
in portland had to deal with the antifa
lunatics
without the rapid response team because
as you know last week they decided all
to resign
sick and tired of the way they were
being treated and even one of their
members
prosecuted by the multnomah county d.a
who is given a pass to all the antifa
lunatics who are attacking cops
all the time that these cops make the
arrest they get sent to mike schmidt
mike schmidt says yeah i'm not really
going to pursue this but then he goes
after a cop who is doing his job
so you've got a lot of people who are
truly upset and antifa is making this
worse
because if you saw anything that they
were doing online last night they were
just making stuff up
and the intent is to get people riled up
and then commit acts of violence and i
do think that portland is living on
borrowed time at this point
because at some point this is going to
become bigger the cops are not going to
be staffed to handle this
and that's going to be a significant
issue that the city is going to have to
deal with and it won't stop
at portland by the way it's just the
most acute just just the most extreme
jason rantz always good to talk to you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else